[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 78
lactu le journal de la rédaction merci
donc de nous rejoindre il est 18h en ce
28 avril et avant de découvrir les
principaux titres nous sommes en ligne
avec Jean-Philippe my député PS de la
11e circonscription des ivelines bonsoir
à vous oui bonsoir vous étiez au côté de
Manuel Vals le Premier ministre à Rome
ce weekend 1 million de pèlerins à
l'occasion des deux canonisations de
jean-23 et de Jean-Paul 2 la classe
politique a contesté ce déplacement de
Manuel Vals à Rome manuel Vals qui a
aussi été hué par une partie des des
pèin présent comment avez-vous vécu vous
ce ce voyage et que pensez-vous de ces
réactions politiques alors il faut
savoir que Manuel Vals est tout à fait
dans son dans son rôle manuel Vals est
la délégation française qui va au
Vatican je rappelle à ceux qui euh qui
qui qui en d'AES qui ne le savent pas
que évidemment le catholicisme est une
grande tradition spirituelle mais
également le Vatican est un état et à ce
titre le Vatican a des relations
diplomatique avec pratiquement tous les
gouvernements et T tous les États dans
le monde la France a d'ailleurs une
ambassade au Vatican comme beaucoup
d'autres beaucoup d'autres pays il faut
voir ça comme un geste d'apaisement
aussi peut-être envers les catholiques
français après la manif pour tous le
printemps français aussi peut-être je
vais juste rappeler aussi que lors du du
vote pour le mariage pour tous vous vous
étiez abstenu à l'Assemblée oui tout à
fait moi je n'ai pas je n'ai pas voté ce
ce ce projet de loi pour pour des tas de
raisons et en particulier pour ce que ça
emportait comme conséquence vis-à-vis
d'affiliation je voudrais quand même
rappeler et vous dire et vous pourriez
confirmer que en regardant les faits
manuel Vals n'a pas été hué par par des
par par des manifestants il se trouve
que franchement une ampleur a été donnée
au fait que alors que il y avait
énormément de gens à Rome et des grands
écrans qui étaient un petit peu partout
dans la ville à un moment alors que des
des Français l'ont vu sur un écran
devant le palet farnais il a été
franchement sifflé par une petite
minorité honnêtement de français bon qui
sont très encore militants certainement
de la manif pour tous B tout ça ne
mérite pas vraiment vraiment l'ampleur
que que que certains médias que certains
médias des des chaînes d'information en
continu ont donné à ce qui est vraiment
un léger incident honnêtement à aucun
moment personnellement physiquement
manuel Vals n'a été n'a été n'a été hué
pour revenir sur ce déplacement sur la
raison aussi de votre présence pourquoi
manuel Vals a fait a décider de faire
appel à à plusieurs députés pour
l'accompagner alors la délégation
française était composée de bon le
Premier ministre manuel Val c'est quatre
parlementaires deux députés PS et de
deux sénateurs UMP et et évidemment moi
ça a été c'est un grand honneur et une
grande joie évidemment que de faire
partie de cette
délégation évidemment manuel Vals
connaît mes conviction il sait ce que je
suis et donc évidemment il faut y voir
certains signes dans cette dans cette
dans cette demande dans cette
invitation de ce point de vue manuel
Vals mais aussi le gouvernement ont
compris que sur certains sujets on ne
pouvait pas comme ça quoi qu'on en pense
queles que soient les convictions des
uns et des autres
on ne pouvait pas passer en force il
fallait il fallait discuter écouter la
société discuter pratiquer plutôt le le
compromis la bonne négociation l'écoute
de l'autre plutôt que que le passage en
force on en revient à cette question
donc sur ce ce geste d'apaisement
peut-être envers les les catholiques qui
expliquent ce déplacement merci
Jean-Philippe my d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous député de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines député
socialistes qui était donc au côté de
Manuel Vals lors de ce voyage à pour la
double canonisation nous passons à
présent au titre de l'actualité locale
de ce 28 avril le maire de Montini le
bretonne devient le premier président de
centre droit de l'agglomération de 50
ans en iveline à l'issue du conseil
communautaire de ce weekend la
contestation se poursuit après les
annonces en fin de semaine du nouveau
ministre de l'Éducation Benoît Amon
autour des rythmes scolaires il souhaite
un assouplissement à ses opposants
veulent un retrait de la mesure initiée
par son prédécesseur Vincent péon mais
Sénat chirurgie cardiaque permett à des
enfants souffrant de malformation
cardiaque de de venir en France et
d'être opéré lorsqu'ils ne peuvent être
soignés dans leur pays d'origine par
manque de moyens financiers et techniqu
afin de récolter et des fonds se
déroulera demain mardi la 17e édition du
Trophée du cœur au golf de Saint-Non la
bretche nous en parlerons sur ce plateau
avec nos invités tout à l'heure l'image
du jour c'est le lancement de la
campagne pour les européennes de
l'alternative modem et udi en
Île-de-France les deux formations
partent ensemble donc sous cette
étiquette alternative pour le scrutin
afin de présenter leur colistier les
deux têtes de liste sur la région Mariel
de Sarnez et Jean-Marie Cavada avaient
donné rendez-vous à la presse à la
Maison de jean-monay à basos sur
guillonne en 2009 lors des précédentes
élections le modem avait totalisé 9 % en
Île-de-France et 10 % dans le
département des ilines nous en parlerons
là aussi plus en détail dans notre
édition de demain mardi mais tout
d'abord êtes-vous intéressé par ce
scrutin européen allez-vous voter tout
simplement pour les européennes vos
réponses avec ce micro trottoir
honnêtement euh je non parce que je
n'étais même pas au courant que ça
allait arriver d'accord voilà donc non
mais si après je peux me pencher dessus
et puis je verrai oui oui bien sûr ben
parce que je crois que c'est un acte
citoyen et et que ça concerne mon avenir
et C du bon pays non j'ai pas encore
pensé et pourquoi euh parce qu'en fait
on on a voté là pour les pour les é les
dernières élections et et là on n'est
pas pour l'Europe on n'est pas tellement
on se sent pas tellement concerné encore
euh oui parce que c'est un devoir de
citoyen non je savais même pas qu'il y
avait d'ex européenne d'une part et puis
bon j'ai pas d'idée sur la question je
me suis un peu retiré de la politique
donc je sais pas trop bien sûr faut
voter c'est important oui il y a pas de
souci c'est la première chose à faire
voilà sachez que sur TV fil la campagne
européenne débutera le 5 mai avec des
reportages des explications sur le rôle
des instances européennes et sur les
incidences aussi sur leurs décisions sur
notre vie quotidienne et puis de débats
à noter 6 et 20 mai ce sont des mardis à
18h30 en direct avec des candidats
présents sur les listes des différentes
formations en Île-de-France autre
élection locale celle de l'agglomération
de CTIN au niveline un mois après les
municipales les élus locaux des SEP
communes qui la composent se sont réunis
samedi afin de désigner leur président
sans surprise c'est Michel logier qui
devient le premier président de centre
droit Catherine zulato yolen Torz
Anthony
Resche avec 25 voix et 23 abstentions
celle de l'opposition michelog été lu
sans surpris ce samedi président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 50 ans
niveline un sentiment de fierté un
sentiment aussi de vivre une étape
importante puisque c'est historique que
un président de droite préside au
destiné aujourd'hui de la communauté
d'agglomération dans son discours
d'introduction devant une salle comble
Michel logie a parlé d'ambition et
d'action avec comme première priorité
mieux cerner l'état financier de la
communauté d'agglomération dans un
contexte de désengagement de l'État et
donc de maîtrise des
budgets donc on va faire différents
audits qui vont nous permettre d'avoir
une vision précise des capacités
financières de la communauté d'agloot de
son organisation administrative et puis
aussi un petit peu savoir ce qui se
passe au niveau de la culture puisque
c'était un point important sur lesquels
ces dernières années on s'est battu sans
avoir beaucoup de réponses dans son
discours Michel og a souhaité aussi
rassurer le personnel administratif les
habitants et les chefs d'entreprise la
première vice-présidence déléguée à
Jean-Michel fourgousse le maire
d'élancour est d'ailleurs consacré au
développement économique et aux finances
c'est un signe fort justement on connaît
très bien hein Jean-Michel Fourgous on
sait très bien sa passion pour le monde
de l'entreprise donc je crois que c'est
un signe important donné aujourd'hui aux
chefs d'entreprise de Saint-Quentin la
deuxième vice-présidence revient
Alexandra Rosetti maire de voisin le
Bretonneux qui aura en charge
l'aménagement en tout 12 vice-présidents
sont été attribués dont quatre pour
l'opposition sans grandamb obtient par
exemple les transports et la circulation
Benoît amamont ministre de l'Éducation
et élu à trappe ne dispose pas du
vice-présidence François deignier le
maire de guilloncour lui s'occupera de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la vie
étudiante j'ai noté qu'il y avait une
volonté de continué par rapport à la
préservation de la réussite de 50 ans en
Yveline je dois dire à titre personnel
que je je seraiis très très attentif à
la poursuite des service de qualité
auprès des habitants parce que nous
sommes là pour les habitants et
notamment avec le le premier des rôles
c'est celui de la solidarité j'ai trouvé
des manques c'est sur la question de la
culture les prochains conseils
communautaires devrai apporter plus
d'éclaircissement sur les nouveaux modes
de fonctionnement de l'agglomération
dorénavant gouverné par la droite une
première à 50 ans
nivin une agglomération qui connaît
l'alternance et forcément des
ajustements vous l'avez entendu dans
l'équipe dirigeante quels sont plus
précisément les postes de vice-président
et surtout à qui ont-ils été confiés
faisons un point plus précis avec ce
sujet sur la nouvelle organisation de 50
Ann
12 vice-présidents et trois conseillers
supplémentaires pour siéger au bureau de
l'agglomération c'est la nouvelle
majorité bien à droite dans cette
assemblée elle n'est que de deux voix et
quatre des SEP communes restent à gauche
dans ce contexte les choix du nouveau
président ont été particulièrement
surveillés Michel logier a donc décidé
de miser sur l'ouverture et de confier
quatre postes aux élus de gauche ainsi
Sandrine grangamb pour trappe sera en
charge du transport François de Ligier
pour Guill en cours de l'enseignement
supérieur Bertrand Ouillon pour
maniléamot du service public des réseaux
et Alain hajage pour la verrière du
développement durable vous avez des
vice-présidents euh issus des communes
de gauche et qui ont des responsabilités
importantes he j'ai pas donné de petites
délégations ce sont de grosses
importantes délégations et on va essayer
de fonctionner de la même façon je
maintient bien sûr le conseil des maires
c'est important aussi que les SEP maires
aient une vision un peu commune de
l'évolution de notre territoire on
aurait pu aller encore plus loin dans le
le partage de la gouvernance par exemple
vous avez vu que sur les vice-présidents
il y a des places données avec des
réeles
délégations à la à la gauche néanmoins
en proportion faible surtout quand on
pense que trois délégués sont ajoutés et
uniquement pour la droite donc on
commence avec un bon principe mais on
l'applique pas jusqu'au bout ça sera
notre rôle de veiller à ce qu'il soit
mieux appliqué en tout cas nous y
prendrons toute notre part l'opposition
a néanmoins fait le choix de
l'apaisement pour la responsable dans le
département du PS qui siège donc aussi à
Saint-Quentin cela passait déjà
symboliquement par l'absence de
candidats lors du vote samedi matin pour
le nouveau président c'était aussi un
message envoyé de dire on est dans une
logique de travail commun euh ça veut
pas dire que on aura pas des exigences
ça veut pas dire qu'à un moment donné on
n'est pas capable de claquer la porte si
vraiment on voit que ça ne va pas dans
le sens qui nous convient mais pour
l'instant on part sur l'idée que on fait
confiance on le verra aussi au moment où
on votera d'autres délibérations sur le
règlement intérieur voir comment
la minorité est respectée c'est sur la
place de la culture et de la santé que
les élus de gauche se veulent le plus
vigilants la priorité ét en clairement
donné pour cette mandature à l'économie
avec un poste de Premier Vice-Président
spécifique confié à Jean-Michel Fourgous
merdélencour Michel logier se veut en
tout cas rassurant lors de son discours
d'installation il s'est adressé au
personnel administratif avant de
préciser que pour l'instant aucune coupe
budgétaire sèche ne serait annoncée
laissez-nous arriver laissez-nous voir
comment les choses sont et puis ensuite
ben on verra ce que nous ser mené à
faire mais il faudra prendre nos
responsabilités en sachant
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez aussi un
désengagement de l'État important et
donc c'est à nous aussi à pouvoir
équilibrer ces
choses-là Benoît amont a dévoilé la
nouvelle feuille de route pour la mise
en place de la mesure phare de son
prédécesseur au ministère de l'Éducation
quelques aménagements sont possibles sur
cette réforme des rythmes scolaires mais
elle devra obligatoirement rentrer en
vigueur dès le mois de septembre Olivier
Manis calco Patrick Jacques de
dixmud une réforme scolaire assoupli
c'est en substance ce que Benois àont
nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale a annoncé vendredi dernier
principale modification par rapport à la
version précédente la durée de la
semaine pourrait être réduite d'une
heure passant de 24 à 23 he
d'enseignement hebdomadaire les 36
heures perdues annuellement seraient
donc rattrapé durant des vacances
scolaires raccourcies un changement
minime qui ne sauve pas une réforme mise
en place trop rapidement et impopulaire
auprès des parents comme ici à trrappe
devant l'école Jean jour comme
d'habitude nos amis technocrates
prennent des décisions sans jamais
concerter le peuple donc je sais pas si
c'est appel à
changer je sais que les trpistes ont
envie que ça change franchement je sais
pas trop mais bon si on garde ancien
rythme ça serait beaucoup mieux même si
la semaine de 4 jours et demi est
conservée l'autre nouveauté c'est la
possibilité de concentrer toutes les
activités périscolaires sur une
demi-journée mais là aussi les critiques
fusent notamment sur le contenu de ces
activités 80 % des communes de France
qui ont expérimenté ça se passe comme ça
ça finit en garderie donc aller
désorganiser la vie des des parents des
grands parents des associations qui
travaillent là-dessus des animateurs des
mairies des profs des enfants surtout
tout ça pour aboutir à un tel résultat
et en plus être incapable de dire on
arrête ça ne marche pas ce qui est assez
emblématique ici on est dans la commune
sur lequelle le ministre de l'éducation
est élu en tant que conseiller municipal
et on peut pas dire que ce qui est mis
en place sur trap soit exemplaire à la
fois en matière de dialogue avec les
parents et les enseignants et en matière
de de la qualité de ce qui est proposé
aux enfants 15 % des municipalités
françaises ont pour l'instant adopté
cette réforme dans leurs écoles dès la
rentrée prochaine elles seront toutes
concernées par ces nouveaux horaires une
rentrée qui s'annonce
mouvementer voilà invité de ce journal à
présent François Babou bonsoir vous êtes
trésorier bénévole de l'association
Mesen chirurgie cardiaque merci d'être
venu jusqu'à nous demain se déroulera la
17e édition du it du cœur c'est une
compétition de golf organisée à saintnon
la bretche afin de récolter des fonds
pour votre cause on va parler de cette
cause justement mais c chirurgie
cardiaque qui a été fondé en 96 1996 sur
l'initiative d'une femme médecin pour
venir en aide à ses confrères de pays ù
le manque de moyens condamnés les
enfants est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus sur cette action concrètement
comment cela se traduit aujourd'hui
écoutez ça se traduit d'une façon hél
très simple il y a enfants sur 1000 dans
le monde qui sont atteints de mal
formation cardiaque et qui ont la
nécessité d'être opéré sinon ils vont
pas dépasser entre 10 et 12 ans et et
période pendant lequelle leur vie ne
sera pas confortable donc dans ces pays
défavorisés tant sur le plan financier
que sur le plan technique euh ils ne
peuvent pas être opérés donc l'action du
professeur Leca euh la femme dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure qui est la
première femme à avoir été en France
professeur en chirurgie cardiaque est
une l'action c'est de faire venir les
enfants en France les accueillir dans
des familles d'accueil bénévole pour
économiser des journées d'hôpital les
les opérer bien sûr et les sortir le
plus tôt possible en toute
sécurité du monde hospitalier pour
pouvoir être toujours dans cette famille
d'accueil où ils vont passer leur
convalescence depuis 1996 quel bilan on
peut faire de votre action ce sont des
centaines d'enfants qui ont été sauvés
2400 et ça avance chaque année parce
qu'au début on opérait qu'à Paris et que
maintenant on opère dans dans huit
villes de province euh les les grands
centres parce qu'on peut pas opérer les
enfants dans tous les dans tous les
centres chirurgicaux c'est une
technologie très pointue et ça nous
permet justement de d'éparpiller si vous
voulez et et de recueillir beaucoup plus
d'enfants comment ces enfants sont
signalés justement à un médecin
chirurgie cardiaque écoutez c'est très
simple c'est soit maintenant parce qu'il
y a quand même Internet dans certaines
capitales euh peut-être pas dans la
brousse mais dans la brousse il y a
aussi le taxi Bru et autre chose donc
ils nous sont signalés par des médecins
par des associations par des
congrégations religieuses parfois par
des journalistes et donc à partir de ce
moment-là se mettre en route tout le
processus pour savoir à peu près ce
qu'il a
prédiagnostique et ensuite de ça voir
s'il est nécessaire de le faire venir
pour l' pérer et le renvoyer chez lui
avec une nouvelle vie d'enfant avec un
cœur tout neuf tout cela coûte très cher
ça nécessite forcément des fonds des
fonds qui sont récolté lors de
différents événements dont cette
compétition de golf qui va se dérouler
demain nouvelle édition du Trophée du
cœur comment ça va se dérouler entre 300
400 participants qui vont mettre un peu
la main à la poche 390 pour l'instant
mais il faut pas aller trop loin parce
que sinon c'est au détriment du confort
du joueur si vous voulez donc il faut
pas essayer d'en avoir trop euh et puis
le terrain il n'a jamais que même s'il
est superbe et il n'a jamais que de fois
18 trous donc on peut accueillir en
serrant beaucoup on peut accueillir à
peu près 380 390 compétiteurs et chaque
participant ver chaque participant verse
une certaine somme mais il a à la fois
il peut joindre l'agréable à l'utile et
puis il y a pas mal d'à côté qui sont
sympathiques il y a un Parin de choix
cette année d'iboun qui viendra alors
comment ça s'est fait cette rencontre
puisque c'est Parin de laassociation un
petit peu comme tout ce qui nous arrive
ça s'est fait naturellement nous avons
par l'intermédiaire de Philippe
archambau qui est le directeur du du du
golf nous avons appris que Dani boun
était
était membre du du du club alors par son
intermédiaire ben on l'a contacté et
puis très gentiment il était à Paris à
ce moment-là et il a accepté de de venir
parrainer l'opération et je pense que
c'est une première marche on verra bien
évidemment demain sur cette antenne
résumé de cette cette compétition en
présence de de ce parrain de prestige
régulièrement vous faites ce type
d'action pour récolter des fonds 24h du
M il y a une participation la gentleman
du cœur aussi c'est une course cycliste
cette fois-ci des opérations qui sont
indispensable c'est les sources
premières de revenus ce sont ces
opérations j'ajoute non mais j'ajouterai
le Tour de France aussi qui est pas
négligable euh non non il y a si vous
voulez il y a il y a deux sortes elles
sont pas Tang de la Motte aussi on a vu
les images par exemple V des globes et
ce noublie pas ce qui se passe c'est que
on a soit des dons particuliers soit des
entreprises qui qui sont partenaires et
qui nous donne de l'argent ou nous donne
du
matériel et puis il y a les opérations
parce que les opérations ont ceci
d'intéressant c'est qu'ils ont deux
volets le premier c'est de faire
connaître et le second c'est de
rapporter de l'argent je revient
justement à ces maladies cardiaques he
qui touchent les enfants dans les pays
où les problèmes financiers sont un
frein à ces opérations à ces traitements
est-ce qu'il y a une évolution malgré
tout ces dernières années est-ce que ça
fait aussi partie de votre travail que
d'accompagner les médecins sur place
pour permettre les opérations sur place
tout à fait on a créé
une une série de de formations pour nous
permettre d'avoir des médecins référents
d'arriver plus vite au bon diagnostic et
puis de pouvoir permettre à une seconde
chose aussi ce qui est le parrainage
parrainer c'est bien de sauver un enfant
mais si s'il doit rester in culte c'est
peut-être pas très très nécessaire donc
grâce à la générosité des familles
d'accueil qui parenent la scolarité des
enfants on peut on peut aller encore un
peu plus loin et c'est par le biais de
ces médecins que nous avons formé et qui
sont référents dans les pays en question
où on peut trouver la bonne personne
pour pas envoyer de l'argent comme ça et
on sait pas ce que ça devient mais que
ce soit vraiment pour payer les études
de l'enfant en question aujourd'hui vos
besoins ce sont des fonds pour permettre
ces opérations ce sont des bénévoles
pour accueillir les enfants quel message
on peut passer ce soir ce soir on peut
passer ces deux messages là plus merci
beaucoup plus celui à tout hasard des
familles d'accueil on a toujours besoin
de famille d'accueil plus on a d'enfants
plus on a besoin de famille d'accueil il
faut savoir que ces 8 semaines s'occupé
d'un enfant comme si c'était le sien
mais toutes les familles d'accueil que
j'ai rencontré depuis 17 ans me disent
on croyait donner et on a beaucoup reçu
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
parler du travail de messena Chirurgie
Cardiaque les coordonnées qui s'affiche
une fois de plus à l'écran n'hésitez pas
à les solliciter et nous reviendrons
bien sûr sur votre compétition de de
golf demain pour récolter des fonds qui
se déroulera en présence de danim boun
au golf de Sainton la Bretèche merci
encore à vous merci à vous culture à
présent 29 30 avril la ferme de bb
guuill en cour qui va présenter chat
land la restitution d'une création
théâtrale écrite avec des jeunes et
interprété par des jeunes une histoire
d'amour sur la toile entre deux
adolescents confrontés aux nouvelles
formes de communication une histoire
d'amour 2.0 à travers les réseaux
sociaux Aurélia debissi et Jonathan
vilman Nissou 7.8 et molocoste deux
pseudonymes derrière lesquels se cachent
deux adolescents en quête d'amour à
travers leurs écrans il chatent se
rencontrre virtuellement se découvre sur
la toile mais pour combien de temps et
que se passera-t-il une fois dans la
vraie vie c'est une histoire d'amour qui
va mal tourner entre deux
adolescents parce qu'il y a des relais
qui sont pas des relais humains mais des
relais justement technologiques qui qui
créent des rumeurs et des et des choses
fausses sur ces deux adolescents et qui
les emprisonnent dans un endroit dont
ils ne peuvent plus sortir c'est ces
outils qui sont à la fois géniaux parce
que très rapides et qui permettent voilà
une plus grande connaissance du monde et
de l'autre et en même temps qu' la
freine dans une dans une réalité écrit
par Dominique sier est mise en scène par
Aurélie van dundal Chatland est la
restitution d'une création théâtrale
écrite avec des jeunes et interprété par
des jeunes cinquantinois une fiction à
la frontière du réel dans laquelle la
mise en scène relève le défi
d'incorporer les nouvelles technologies
tout en conservant la théâtralité et le
jeu des comédiens pour moi c'est très
important de parler de des nouvelles
technologies au théâtre qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en faire comment on peut les
exploiter et c'était l'enjeu du projet
puisque c'est de parler de des dérives
des R r sociaux et de
l'incommunicabilité à travers les
nouveaux médias la mise en scène c'est
une alternance de séquence entre ces
moments très intime que nous on a choisi
de poser dans des vestiaires qui sont un
petit peu pour nous la chambre
adolescente et un univers de gymnase
très collectif très publ dans lequel on
doit se donner à voir autant sport donc
autant le corps que que le groupe en
fait et comment on est face au groupe
Chatland une adaptation 2.0 de Roméo et
Jul est à découvrir gratuitement les 29
et 30 avril à la ferme de bbas à
guillanire merci de nous avoir suivi le
journal qui revient donc demain d 18h en
direct je recevrai Michel logier le
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération vous pouvez consulter
nos précédentes éditions et nos
précédents reportages grâce au replay
sur le site internet excellente soirée
vous avez notamment rendez-vous sur
TVfil avec Anthony rche pour le 78 sport
à
demain
[Musique]